that's because the long awaited what
they're calling the drop a can of
construction because it actually drops
tomorrow yeah this is around the
Tropicana Avenue area and the I-15 we
can expect traffic impacts across the
valley as Muse mentioned for a year and
a half in some parts Ryan Matthey joins
us live with how drivers can navigate it
all Ryan
yeah Denise and Kirsten if you remember
over the Christmas holiday weekend we
had a 12 mile traffic back up on the
I-15 closer to State Line but officials
say we could get some of those headaches
over here on the Tropicana Bridge that's
all while Crews knock it down to make it
wider more accessible and safer it
starts tomorrow night with the
southbound exit ramp closure it's in
preps for larger closures that begin
next week it includes a three-day hard
close of the I-15 between Russell and
Flamingo but the Tropicana bridge over
the stretch will be closed until summer
2024. an ndot representative says there
will be posted detours and extra police
officers staffed in areas expected to
see the most traffic congestion but with
the busiest interchange in Nevada or one
of them closing at least he adds that
some preparations fall on the driver
we suggest using navigation apps like
Waze and Apple Maps I'm in frequent
contact with the real life
representatives from those apps and so
they are very familiar with our closure
area our timing the best bet is to if
you can avoid the area do so and if you
do need to go to the Las Vegas Strip or
one of the businesses along Tropicana
Avenue plan ahead and try and find the
best route ahead of time
now he adds that traffic signal timing
may be adjusted on roads impacted the
most he says that's the most efficiently
get these congested areas cleared on out
but the biggest suggestion they have is
downloading this app you just gotta look
up I-15 drop it's going to have all the
information on those closures the
detours and any other information you're
going to need for again the next year
and a half reporting live near the I-15
and Tropicana Ryan Matthey 8 News Now
thank you Ryan the southbound exit ramp
closures vary depending on where you're
going westbound away from the strip will
reopen nine months time the flyover ramp
toward the strip however will be 18
months